for some people Broadway may seem like
it's just for Die Hard theater fans but
truly it is for everybody it makes you
feel so good live theater is so good so
no matter um your Walk of Life or where
you live live shows are accessible many
Broadway hits like shucked end up
touring the country so you get a chance
to see them if you're not in New York so
today we are launching a new segment
which I love Broadway and
[Music]
[Applause]
sixa and I love that it's your show I
love that it's your show y'all have no
idea how Full Circle this is it's so
cool so not only are we giving viewers
an inside look at some of the theater
District's best we are also sending a
Broadway newbie to see a show so this is
Dave he is a lifelong New Yorker and
retired tour guide who never goes to
theater just doesn't do that right so um
what would he think of shucked while we
sent him to the show last night to find
out
so I'm not that your Broadway guy but
tonight I'm here to seek shucked it
sounds like a great
play it's about cor how was they going
get two hours about
cor I'm here in the lobby and they're
still coming in it looks like a sold out
crowd it's going to be great I am really
excited terrific seats lot of energy
I'll let you know tomorrow what I think
and a few L everybody will perform a
song uh but first let's talk to Dave a
lifelong New Yorker who never attends
Broadway we sent him to see shucked for
his honest review of the musical so
you're not usually into Broadway shows
right nope n you would think as a
lifelong New Yorker I would be but I've
been a tour guide for 38 years okay you
were busy the time yeah busy yeah I'm a
little disappointed it's fine um I'm
just kidding so so you're you're ready
to share your thoughts right yep now I
asked about and I said two hours of corn
I mean like get real
but but it was delightful isn't it funny
it is among other things it is a really
really great show it's the type of show
that everyone is going to love okay you
need to see it like uh the guy back
there more than once because the jokes
are a little bit you have to wait three
or 4 seconds to laugh at them he's very
but that's fine but that's fine what I
really loved was the music the music how
you melded the music
and the dialogue and comedy together I'm
watching you could see that all the
players the actors really liked doing it
they liked each other and they enjoyed
it they everybody likes getting paid but
you could see they would have done it
for free yes they would have done it for
free that's why you see they liked it I
getting paid they would have done it for
free da because you could see their
camera I think he's going to have to be
he's going to have to be the regular guy
that goes to see who else is going to do
this for you the guy the guy that should
have paid you to be in the cast was Bo
he got to kiss a beautiful girl hug her
a few times and at the end of the week
they give him a paycheck they do he gets
a kiss a beautiful girl and they pay you
for this paid for can I get this job
exactly you would be awesome in corn
yeah
shocked you would be awesome in corn
too kiss beautiful girls and they give
you money exactly
I love where your mind's at Dave okay
well now it's time to judge for yourself
Dave can you take it from here yep we
are performing we love Jesus You're
Gonna Love this it's got everything corn
singing dancing comedy even booze nice
here is the C
shocked here we are Kelly Clarks with
our little farm to Fable
better send a pigeon cuz cob County
ain't got
cable if we ain't praying then we're
drinking if we ain't drinking then we're
dead so bring a bottle and a bible let
get in your
head
Church on W chances into thees are
tripl that Lees
us all kind of crazy to get yeah we love
Jesus but we drink a
little a little too too we
there's
out we turn wine we turn corn shine yeah
we love Jesus but we drank a little
we're up with the rooster man got AIG B
and Callan with unle sing
[Applause]
every we we love Jesus but we Dr little
come too late a little too early you get
thirsty yeah we
[Music]
got we turn Cor in shine yeah we love
Jesus but we drink a little
[Music]
like a little J like a
little like a little kiss and like a
little we like a little B we like a
little
Be Love a little butt in
some we're like a little cow like a
little cow like a little TI a little TI
like a little
[Music]
SK like a little like a
little we there
[Music]
some water is we turn corn in shine love
Jesus we love
Jesus
[Music]
de we love Jesus but we
[Applause]
[Music]
Dr
[Applause]
thank you guys y'all have a great night
I'm going
home